auch die Männer bitte nicht schminken
also wenn hier Make-up drin ist dann ist
der ganz klar nicht für Männer denn
Barbara möchte natürlich nicht dass
Männer sich schminken es kann sein dass
Sie sich für diese Aussage schon wieder
entschuldigt hat und so aber noch im
Kopf hängen geblieben hallo Leute hier
ist wieder eure Vanessa und heute packen
wir den Adventskalender von der Barbara
Schöneberger aus was kostet mich das
gute Ding wir sind bei
diesem Art von
89,99 und er hat einen unschlagbaren
Warenwert von 300 €. okay Sam beauty
Adventskalender ich dachte das ist ein
beauty Adventskalender der Kalender ist
nicht direkt von Barbara Schöneberger
selbst sondern in Zusammenarbeit mit
Beauty love und die haben auch den
Brigitte Adventskalender pink Box
Adventskalender und den Blackbox
mandalender 300 €, ich bin gespannt ihr
seht ich habe meinen Pussy runs
everything T-Shirt an das kann nur
bedeuten dass ich ein paar Produkte auch
mal ausprobieren möchte und sie mir
direkt ins Gesicht klatschen werde
dieser Kalender ist wieder so ein Fall
von wegen warum habe ich noch nicht mein
eigenen und alle anderen schon Barbara
Schöneberger ist eine Person die was
verbinde ich mit Barbara Schöneberger
bitte nicht schminken die moderiert
alles mögliche sie hat sogar mal den
videopreis moderiert was ein bisschen
komisch war weil sie sich überhaupt
nicht mit Verb Video auskannte und man
ist ein bisschen gemerkt hat aber ja
schreibt mir gerne eure Gedanken zu
Barbara Schöneberger in die Kommentare
und wir beginnen jetzt auch schon es ist
ein wiederverwendbarer Adventskalender
das heißt man kann Boxen im nächsten
Jahr selbst befüllen und sich dann einen
großen Spaß draus machen Nummer eins
aber eine Sache muss ich schon sagen
fällt schon extrem auf dass die sich
alle ein bisschen
copypay sein angeht ich meine das
Prinzip ist cool mit den Boxen aber dass
sie dann manche Worte so ausschreiben
und dann manchmal eine fette Zahl hin
haben manchmal eine kleine Zeit also es
ist so 100 Mal gesehen ich würde jetzt
auch keine Alternative wissen aber das
Design und seht ihr was ich meine hier
bleibt das Zeug drin nicht wie beim Paul
Valentine Adventskalender ich habe ganze
Zeit falsch ausgesprochen ich weiß nicht
wie das andere hinkriegen und warum das
hier nicht so ist aber das fällt
ziemlich leicht raus Nummer eins es gibt
wieder einen Gruß der schönste Grund
morgens aufzustehen ist der
Adventskalender das würde ich
unterschreiben ich weiß gar nicht was da
drin sein könnte beste Dusche
Maracuja Mangobutter
aus also ich bin Fan von Mango Maracuja
deswegen liebe ich den Duft sehr ja
feste Dusche ne kann man eigentlich
nichts falsch machen aber wenn ich einen
Warenwert von 300 € höre muss ich das
kontrollieren 5 € 99 bei Sachen die ich
nicht direkt ausprobieren kann könnt ihr
gerne reinschreiben falls ihr Erfahrung
mit den Produkten habt kann man sich ja
in den Kommentaren ein bisschen
austauschen Weihnachtsmarkt ist so lange
Glühwein zu trinken bis einem Sachen aus
Filz gefallen das ist ein guter Spruch
der Mensch hier macht es ein bisschen
mehr Sinn ne das just Spice ist Glühwein
gewürzt warum hat sich das nicht Daniela
Katzenberger reingemacht anstatt für
Hackfleisch lass mich raten 5,99 €, 4,99
und wartet mal hier sind Spruch zum
Weihnachtsmarkt und Glühwein trinken und
dann bekommt man ein Glühweingewürz
das wird noch mal ganz kurz
kontrollieren was standen bei der eins
okay der schönste kommt morgens
aufzustehen ist der Adventskalender aber
morgens aufstehen duschen das hat schon
irgendwo eine und bin gespannt ob sich
das durchzieht Nummer drei ist ein
kleines Geschenk Glück muss man teilen
damit es mehr wird
und jetzt ist hier
das sieht ehrlich gesagt aus wie so eine
Karte für meinen neuen Tesla
eine sehr schöne Palette mit Farben die
man definitiv immer wieder gebrauchen
kann
guck mal wie die helle Farbe heißt van
essa das finde ich cool aber der Teilen
Spruch macht jetzt hier keinen Sinn weil
eine Lidschatten Palette teilt man sich
jetzt nicht wirklich ich finde es
wirklich sehr komisch dass hier nichts
drauf ist von wegen nach 12 Monaten dann
wegschmeißen oder das sind die
Inhaltsstoffe was ich sage jetzt mal 30
Euro aber ich verstehe nicht warum die
ganze Zeit bei Ebay vertickert wird 30
Euro für so wenig ich weiß noch nicht ob
ich die behalten möchte deswegen benutze
ich sie noch nicht packt da meine
Patcher Finger rein das kann sein dass
ich sie in die verlosungsbox mit rein
Türchen Nummer 4 pro bis du Nummer vier
Glück ist kostenlos aber dennoch
unbezahlbar
oh ein bienenwachstuch bienenwachstuch
ist auch finde ich so neues Produkt der
nachhaltigen Startup Welle wenn ich es
mal so sagen kann ich habe es
ausprobiert ich bin nicht der größte Fan
davon muss ich ehrlich sagen ich konnte
damit nicht so gut umgehen ist natürlich
besser als Frischhaltefolie oder
Alufolie zu nehmen aber ich hatte das
Gefühl wenn ich dann irgendwie eine
Schüssel hat und das so drum gelegt habe
das hat so lange gedauert und dann war
immer noch irgendwie so ein Löchlein
frei die dieses Bienenwachs Ding das
kann man ja irgendwie ein Jahr benutzen
Zehnerpack mit den S-Bahn wachstüchern
also unverpackt naja ein Zehnerpack
kostet Dings 2 €, ich sag mal 250 die 15
zu finden ist nicht schwer Zeit ist
meine Fingernägel wieder ein bisschen
kürzer werden ich komme damit echt nicht
zurecht ein Plätzchen eine Decke gibt's
den Weihnachtsstress hey na siehst du
und gegen Stress clean Peel
Gesichtsmaske reinigt porentief klärt
und beugt Irritationen vor boah das ist
ein geiles oh man kann es gut quetschen
und die werde ich mir aber gewarnt oder
darauf habe ich bock mir die heute abend
drauf zu machen 75 Cent bis jetzt
gefällt mir der Adventskalender ganz gut
und ich habe Hoffnung dass Nikolaus
jetzt speziell vertreten wird Nummer 6
lieber Nikolaus definiere unartig hat
der Nikolaus auch so eine gut und
schlecht Liste ja follow guckt mal also
ich meine die Lidschattenpalette war
schon toll aber jetzt hier so typische
baborzeug was echt teuer ist klatschen
wir uns doch ins Gesicht die Babor
precious Collection 16,80 €. wir hauen
hier aber auch mit Preisen um die Ecke
so precious heckaching können sie schaut
mal an da kriegt man doch direkt lustig
irgendwas davon ins Gesicht zu klatschen
extra energy direct lifting oder intense
volume wer will denn Volumen sein
Gesicht ganz ehrlich ich brauche Energie
es ist irgendwie schon was es hat schon
was sehr aggressives ne
jedes ist so ein Gelee oh nein nein nein
nein nein es läuft mir alles davon okay
es riecht fantastisch in Korea als sie
mir so Serien und sowas drauf gemacht
haben haben sie immer so richtig so
reingeschlagen eine sehr komische
Konsistenz ist so richtig glitschig
glibschig nass gleichzeitig man kann
sagen was man will auf jeden Fall ein
gesunden Glanz im Gesicht ja ich mag
einfach die Baba Produkte jetzt ist nur
die Frage ob man sich wirklich etwas
kaufen sollte was 5 € pro Anwendung
kostet das ist halt ein Luxusprodukt ne
das ist für eine Preisklasse die sich so
um Geld nicht so viele Gedanken machen
muss und sich dann denkt oh
das kaufen wird und für alle anderen
gibt es das im Adventskalender los mit
der Babo Werbung oh mein Gott ich habe
schon wieder vergessen bevor ich hier
noch irgendwelche Produkte ganz doll
lobe oder ganz oft die Barbara Box sage
oder Beauty love dieses Video ist nicht
gesponsert und jetzt alles dieses Videos
nicht gespannt hat ich habe es jetzt
öfter vergessen
aber das war ein tolles nikolaussprüchen
jetzt kommt die Nummer 7 je älter wir
werden desto kürzer werden unsere
Wunschzettel denn die Dinge die wir uns
wirklich wünschen kann man nicht kaufen
malzig aber ein judeneierlikör du das
ist was ich mir wirklich Wünsche trinken
feiern tanzen mit echtem Übersee rum ich
habe einmal Eierlikör selber gemacht hat
super geschmeckt gekaufter Eierlikör
fertige Eierlikör da kann der noch so
teuer sein das schmeckt einfach komisch
ich erinnere mich gerade an den letzten
ich glaube verporten oder so das
schmeckt so komisch ach mensch wie toll
der ist laktosefrei was anderes weil die
meisten müssen noch Sahne dazu den werde
ich mir gönnen du aber erst nach dem
Oktober denn ich mache es super Oktober
was kostet eine kleine Flasche Schnaps
ich mach 1,50 gut also die Sprüche
passen leider nicht immer ich hätte
gedacht sie zieht das durch Nummer 8
Konfuzius hat gesagt nein Barbara
Schöneberger hat gesagt wenn dir das
Leben Steine in den Weg legt
draufstellen Balance halten Aussicht
genießen Lächeln und weitergehen ha
dieser Spruch ist auf dem Level von
röhnchen richten weitergehen klar und
wenn Du dann auf so einem Stein stehst
brauchst du eine calling Relief
Handcreme Handcreme ist ja praktisch
aber ich pack so viel Adventskalender
aus ich glaube ich hätte 300 Handcremes
wenn ich sie nicht verlosen würde mein
Kollege Leon von X skincare der wüsste
jetzt wahrscheinlich was lipid bedeutet
aber es ist anscheinend eine Creme für
beanspruchte und strapazierte Hände mit
Panthenol ah Panthenol ist gut das weiß
ich das bestimmt eine gute Creme aber
warum nicht einfach ein Spruch zur
Handcreme 17,91 €. wow ich kriege seit
kurzem im Winter super schnell
aufgeplatzte Handy ich brauche nur
dreimal rausgehen wenn es kalt ist und
dann hängt das schon an hier zu reißen
und sonst was zu machen da ist so eine
Creme wahrscheinlich auch sehr praktisch
ich und meine Frisur wollen Euch
herzlich begrüßen zum Türchen Nummer 9
wir wissen Türchen Nummer 9 wird das
beste Türchen sein aller Zeiten
Schneegestöber Tannen Duft Weihnachten
liegt in der Luft hollerspruch und jetzt
kommt das Produkt dass wir alle gewartet
haben
ja okay es muss ja nicht immer das beste
Produkt und natürlich sind halt zwei
Nagel fallen nee
2,80 €. ich habe halt Gelnägel ich kann
damit absolut nichts anfangen über 10
Nummer 10 Barbara sagte mal es ist Zeit
für das was war Danke zu sagen damit das
was wird unter einem guten Stern beginnt
gleich in die Gefühle rein Barbara du
hast es mal wieder geschafft
ich dachte da sind irgendwie leckere
Mandeln oder sowas zum Essen drin ich
habe ein bisschen Bock auf was zum
snacken wunderschönes dieser ich finde
das Produkt so schon mal schön so riecht
Natur hier ist so ein richtig schöner
Text der mich so vor dem
Weihnachtsstimmung bringt du riecht
Natur
riecht nach nix aber ich soll das da
drauf machen genauso muss es doch sein
tolle Weihnachtsprodukte happy Christmas
ah das riecht toll klar es ist Samstag
ne boah mach das ruhig ist okay
es ist irgendwie komisch dass da drauf
zu machen es riecht nach Orange und nach
Panne soll es regnen einfach der und die
Weihnachtsduft oh die Verpackung gefällt
mir sehr gut und das Produkt gefällt mir
auch sehr gut so was hat man echt
seltenen Adventskalender drin das
überrascht mich gerade das ist mal echt
was Neues was aufregend ist 8 € 41 das
kann man auch bei der Apotheke kaufen
also ja jetzt ist doch mal gut danke
Nummer 11 man sagt nicht mehr
Weihnachtsbaum es heißt jetzt extrem
beleuchtetes nagelgehölz mit
religionshintergrund
weiß ich nicht ich fühle den Satz nicht
Louis boah manche Verpackungen sind so
komisch so so leuchtend auf Dings Level
wer kann das denn da lesen boah das
riecht intensiv boah das riecht wie die
frischeste Wäsche die jemals gerochen
habe das sauberste Badezimmer was ist
das oh nein ich werde es lieben und es
wird super teuer sein und dann werde ich
mir immer nachkaufen müssen und so viel
Geld und das war genau der Plan von so
einem Adventskalender Produkte rein zu
oh mein Gott das ist sehr das ist das
ist der Inbegriff von einem sauberen
Duft so möchte ich riechen wenn ich
frisch geduscht wow das ist ein Duschgel
das ist sogar zu warum riecht das so
extrem riecht das bei denen in der
Fabrik so doll
oh mein Gott nein ich glaube sogar mein
Großeltern im Badezimmer gerauchen oh
Gott ey
oh Gott ey das ist ein Produkt aus der
Schweiz Apotheke kaufen zweimal 200 m
was ist denn der Literpreis 53 Euro sind
ungefähr Nummer 12 mein liebstes
Wintergemüse ist ja die
marzipan-kartoffel
das ist so richtig Sprüche und das ist
das kleinste Produkt der Welt was ist
das hinter Day Cream und QMS
medicosmetics die hat hier alles so ein
bisschen medizinische Produkte naja das
KaDeWe bietet diese Marke an das heißt
wir wissen was für eine Preisklasse ja
88 Euro 88 € für 50 Milliliter ich mache
hier 0 € weil das ist ja definitiv eine
Probe für die man ja nie was zahlt aber
zu einer Tinte Day Cream sage ich nicht
nein man muss vorsichtig sein mit
solchen Produkten mir scheint es jetzt
schon ein bisschen dunkel aber wenn so
Reihe jetzt diesen Adventskalender hätte
gut es ist nur eine Probe Größe ne das
ist ja dann nicht so schlimm trotzdem
muss man dafür dann halt einfach weiß
sein wenn man das benutzen möchte fällt
auch wieder so ein Luxusprodukt meine
Nachbarn geben alles gerade
ja ihr ja das sollte man echt nicht
machen keine Foundation da rein weil
wofür wir sind jetzt in der zweiten
Halbzeit angekommen bitte
darum hat mich zur Arbeit kommen das
Türchen vom Adventskalender klemmt das
ist ein guter Spruch das ja doch fühle
ich also jetzt reicht aber mal mit den
apothekenprodukten muss ich sagen also
wenn jetzt hier schon wieder irgendwas
kommt was ich bei DocMorris Kriege also
ich weiß nicht was ich von solchen
Produkten halten soll ich habe mir mal
als Teenager von glaube ich Garnier oder
sowas war so eine große gelbe Flasche
Anti celluliten-creme Cellulite hat der
Körper ich das kann man glaube ich auch
nicht mit einer Creme irgendwie besser
machen und das ist jetzt ein Figur ein
shapingoil straft und festigt die
violette ich werde es ausprobieren mit
kann man auf dem ganzen Körper drauf
klatschen straft glättet und Cellulite
wirksam reduziert und Problemzonen wie
Bauch Beine Po und Oberarme gefestigt
also jetzt idealer Begleiter während der
Rückbildung nach der Schwangerschaft was
ist das antizolitische Effekt
klatschmohnsamen Extrakt aktiviert
Fettabbau 10 mal effektiver als Koffein
kann ich eine Creme auftragen und dann
das Fett ich meine wenn es eine gute
Creme ist und sich die Haut da gut
anfühlt freue ich mich aber irgendwie
versprechen die hier gerade dass man
wirklich davon abnehmen also nicht
abnehmen aber das kriegen sie damit
nicht weg das kriegt keine Creme der
Welt Weg gut ich probiere es aus doch
man kann es auch wieder bei DocMorris
kaufen ja 7 € aber ich meine wenn ihr
Erfahrung damit habt schreibt gerne in
die Kommentare ich würde wirklich
interessieren okay Barbara welches
Körperteil soll ich jetzt verbessern ich
habe zum ersten Mal Lebkuchen gebacken
wir hatten noch nie so gute Türstopper
och nee
wieder sehr ein kleines Produkt oh
lavera ist lavera so beliebt hier auch
schon wieder ein la vera Produkt drin
aber Papa Papa Papa Papa Papa William
care Q10 Komplex kann einen neuen Lippen
irgendwas gebrauchen aber es ist so ein
richtiger Lippenstift
mit grünem Q10 Komplex sieht sich das
beste Produkt was ich jemals auf meinen
Lippen hatte aber es ist okay und ich
meine es ist ja bion organic und was
weiß ich was ja wenn es jetzt hier im
Angebot ist man muss schon das Baby ich
das dann kriegen kann ne 5,25 € mach mal
5 € was sagt ihr dazu sehr gut ja schade
die Sprüche sind auf jeden Fall nicht
mehr passend zum Inhalt was ja toll
gewesen wäre 15 ist ein großes Türchen
und auch schwer
jetzt sind wir nicht mehr im KaDeWe
jetzt sind wir bei dm und machen uns ein
Fußbad Fußbäder sind ja was Gutes ich
meine viele Leute haben tatsächlich echt
Stinkefüße und sollten mal was dagegen
machen und so ein Fußbad hilft wirklich
drei Euro aus dieser Spruch dazu
verschenken heißt Liebe zu verteilen
hier in Fußbad vielen Dank so meine
Damen und Herren in der Nummer 16
befindet sich ein toller Spruch Liebe
und Zimtsterne gleich Weihnachten und da
muss jetzt irgendwas mit Zimt drin sein
fühle ich nicht reparaturfestes Shampoo
naturebox packt aber auch wirklich
überall seine Dinge rein in wie vielen
Adventskalender schon dieses Produkt
drin hatte 4,55 € der Spruch für die
Nummer 17 heute machen wir was für
bauchbeine und Po Plätzchen
also spruchmäßig oder ich dachte was zu
essen eine duschbombe Wasser
am Boden ins Wasser weg vom Ablauf legen
Augen schließen und Duft Erlebnis
genießen oh es riecht nach Rose ich bin
kein rosenfan aber das ist eine
duschbombe wenn man Dusch benutzt man
doch Produkte wie z.B das Badezimmer
Duschgel von meinem Opa warum sollte man
in die Dusche noch was reinlegen das von
unten einen Rosenduft kommt und der
Seite kommt dann mein Duschgel dann hat
mein Shampoo noch ein Duft ich habe das
Gefühl dass es einfach zu viel bin da
nicht so für wir sind nicht so 1 €
Nummer 18 je mehr Freude wir anderen
Menschen machen desto mehr Freude kehrt
in unser eigenes Herz zurück
ihr wisst was da drin ist ihr wisst es
ich gebe euch noch einen Moment ihr habt
schon oder die AWO Augencreme die 90 €
kostet und überall drin ist wir haben ja
schon in dem Adventskalender von Daniela
Katzenberger diese Creme gehabt und
jetzt habe ich sogar ein Update für euch
ich habe die die letzten Tage immer mal
wieder benutzt und ich finde sie gut
also sie ist auf jeden Fall nicht
schlecht die fühlt sich gut an die Macht
feucht unter den Augen ja aber ich
wüsste jetzt nicht ob man einen großen
Unterschied wirklich sieht da haben sie
den Warenwert schon wieder hochgetrieben
wir sind 100 € und dann steht da
plötzlich nicht mehr 200 € Warenwert
nein 300 € Warenwert weil hier eine in
zehn teure Creme drin ist okay Nummer 19
nur noch fünf Mal schlafen bis ich
dachte wir schenken uns nicht das ist
doch wieder ein Apotheken das ist ein
Apotheken Adventskalender
Nahrungsergänzung mit Zink und Vitamin C
für Vitalität durch eine normale
Funktion des Immunsystems 7 Kapseln für
den Tag sieben Kapseln für die Nacht
also einfach was fürs Immunsystem ist
das eine Immunkur wahrscheinlich schon
ne ne immer unter Absprache mit eurem
Arzt und Apotheker das sind hier Tag und
Nacht Film der immunchor also ich bin
Freund von sowas ich benutze selber
Nahrungsergänzungsmittel ich glaube
daran dass man sich auch gerade was das
Immunsystem angeht und so dass man sich
ein bisschen pushen kann aber richtiges
apothekenprodukt 14,60 €. aber gut man
muss ja denken was ist denn die
Zielgruppe man kann schon ein bisschen
erkennen was die Zielgruppe sein soll ne
ich sehe so eine Frau ab 40 Punkt
140 okay vorne steht nun eine 2 wir sind
bereit Nummer 20 und wir warten auf
Barbaras tollen Spruch es sind die
gemeinsamen Momente mit unseren Liebsten
die Weihnachten so besonders machen ja
da hast du einfach ja das ist nicht mal
das ist nicht mal lustig das ist einfach
Fake ja aber was soll denn Weihnachten
sonst besonders machen der alverde
NATURKOSMETIK Glitzer Eyeliner metallic
Eyeliner uh für Silvester oder was oh
heute wird ein guter Tag wir müssen aber
nicht ich habe ganz schön viele Eyeliner
zwei Euro 75 okay unser Adventskalender
darf jetzt in Amerika trinken wir haben
das Türchen Nummer 21 sei der Grund das
heute jemand lächelt na toll ja was ist
das Gesichtsmaske aha Gesichtsmaske okay
machen wir zwei Euro 2 und 20
da will man nur mal kurz die Keksdose
Lüften zack ist die Hälfte der Kekse
verdampft ihr kennt das das ja das sind
sehr viele Sprüche von wegen ich fresse
mir gerne einen rein aber verratzt
niemanden oder Moment
oh mein Gott ich liebe es ich liebe
nämlich diese Dinger wo man nicht mit
seinen Händen so gottlos in seinem Mund
rumfassen muss aber ich finde das
natürlich doof dass das dann immer aus
Plastik ist und hier ist es anscheinend
nachwachsender Rohstoff was bedeutet das
ja ich zeige dir Verpackung ohne Plastik
aber ich möchte wissen was das da drin
ist der Griff der pflanzenbasierten
Zahnseide Sticks besteht aus
nachwachsenden Rohstoffen Seiten
recyclebarmen Material aber ich finde
das klingt alles so verwirrend das ist
Plastik warum schreiben sie denn nicht
woraus der Griff ist nachwachsende
Rohstoffe das kann doch alles sein
wie oft benutzt sie eigentlich Zahnseide
3,20 €.
haha
Weihnachten ist keine Jahreszeit es ist
ein Gefühl unintelligible Weihnachten
ist auch kein Jahreszeit weihnachten ist
ein Fest ich feier Weihnachten weil es
für mich ein Familienfest ist einfach ja
kommt mit der Familie zusammen und
trinkt Tee ja guckt mal ein bisschen zu
spät okay heißt Winterfreude feiere die
Gemütlichkeit
wird Gemütlichkeit okay
aber das müsste am Anfang kommen weil
nach Weihnachten ist man auch nicht mehr
so in Orangen Stimmung sein dann geht
irgendwann alles weg und ich meine einen
Tag vor Weihnachten dann hast du
irgendwie also man hat eh so viel Tee
das könnte früher drin sein bei Euro
okay Leute
ist Weihnachten du gehst an deinen
Adventskalender ran er ist schon sehr
leicht irgendwas alles rausgenommen
außer ein Türchen das Türchen Nummer 24
und hier wird sich ein ganz besonderes
Geschenk drin verstecken Weihnachten ist
wenn die besten Geschenke am Tisch
sitzen und nicht unterm Baum liegen die
Sprüche sind immer ein bisschen
wiederholen was wird drin sein es ist
drin ein
massagetool toll wisst ihr was größer
ist dieses kleine grüne Ding da mit dem
man sich durch das Gesicht
durchmassieren kann ich werde das jetzt
nicht aufmachen weil ich das lieber
verlose ich habe sowas ähnliches schon
zu Hause und ich wenn ich das jetzt
anfasse unter mir irgendwie das Gesicht
treibe finde ich das ein bisschen eklig
ja doch das finde ich gut das ist ein
gutes 24 Türchen oh mein Zehner so
dieser tolle wellnesskalender ich weiß
was euch am meisten interessiert wie
viel ist da wirklich drin 300 € in
welcher Welt sind das
300 € und dann 241 €, ne wenn wir dann
noch - diese
endlos Augencreme machen werden wir bei
150 okay diese eine Augencreme die
provoziert mich einfach okay wir sind
bei 20 € wir sind bei 241 €. das ist
nicht 300 € wir haben 90 € gezahlt naja
irgendwie wie so ein großer etwas
größerer DM Einkaufen ne finde ich das
gut ja doch also im Vergleich zum
Daniela Katzenberger Kalender ist das
hier irgendwie wird sich das einfach
besser an ich weiß nicht warum wir haben
plus gemacht wir kriegen mehr als wir
ausgegeben haben das ist einfach ein
Fakt und jetzt ist die Frage also es
sind so ein paar Produkte drin wie die
festen Shampoos das ist halt das muss
man ausprobieren für sich kann man sie
auch irgendwie Teilen mit Freunden wenn
man das jetzt nicht so gerne benutzt
also für mich ist das unseren Apotheken
wellnesskalender also jetzt mal ist das
so die Interesse für die Frau ich weiß
nicht wie alt ist Barbara Schöneberger
48 hey guck mal für die Frau ab 40 da
werde ich schon so ein bisschen Wellness
Apotheken mäßig ja das sind gute
Produkte der ist toll der ist toll ganz
ehrlich mein echtes Fazit dazu ist wenn
ihr viel Geld für eure Mutter ausgeben
möchtet dann holt eure Mama dieses Jahr
den Kalender ernsthaft jetzt der ist für
eine Mama ist der wie gemacht die
Sprüche finden Mamas bestimmt auch toll
und dieser Kalender
hier und wir sehen uns beim nächsten
Video wieder viel Spaß tschüss